and the united states
for the first time in decades
put the carrier a strike group under
nato command
we are considering to further enhance
our presence in the eastern part of the
alliance
this could include the deployment of
additional nato battle groups
these deployments are proportionate and
in line
with our international commitments
and they reinforce european security for
all of us
at the same time nato remains ready to
continue dialogue with russia
following the nato-russia council
earlier this month i have now invited
all members to a series of further
meetings
to address european security including
the situation in and around ukraine
nato russia relations and how to reduce
risks and increase transparency
and arms control disarmament and
non-proliferation
so nato allies are ready to engage in
genuine dialogue and to seek
constructive outcomes
and we will continue to consult with our
key partners finland and sweden
as we take this dialogue forward
let me be clear nato will not compromise
on core principles we stand for the
right of each nation to choose its own
alliances
and nato's door remains open
while nato cooperates closely with
finland and sweden we fully respect your
strong and independent security policies
it is for finland and sweden alone to
decide your own path
not russia
not anyone else
sovereign nations have the right to
self-determination
nato will always respect that
others must respect that too
so
there back out there on
once again welcome to both of you and
thank you again for finland and sweden's
deep friendship and partnership with
nato
our cooperation makes us all safer and
more secure
so then i give the floor to you
thank you secretary general
stoltenbergia james
we had a very good discussion today on
the security situation in eastern europe
and also how it influences to the wider
security also in our region of the
baltic sea region
appreciate the dialogue between nato
finland and sweden very much in the
current situation transatlantic unity is
key
dialogue and diplomatic efforts continue
seeking ways to increase transparency
and trust is welcomed it's positive that
nato remains open to continue its
dialogue with russia in this dialogue of
course both sides are needed
respecting the core principles of
european security is important
challenging the u.n chapter helsinki
final act and the charter of paris for
new europe treaties we have all signed
upon undermines international security
and the rules based international order
defending these principles is now
essential than ever
we cannot return back to the europe with
spares of influence and interest
we welcome that nato has reaffirmed the
continuation of its open door policy
it's a vital element for european
security continuing the policy is
important also for finland
finland engages in pragmatic and
wide-ranging partnership cooperation
with nato since 1994. in recent years
the partnership cooperation with nato
has taken many steps forward finland is
one of nato's six enhanced opportunities
partners
the 30 plus two cooperation between
finland sweden and nato strengthens
stability and predictability in the
baltic sea region the cooperation is
mutually beneficial
yet last october also had an excellent
meeting a visit of nato council to
finland thank you for that
finally finland is not a member of nato
but maintaining a national room to
manuever and freedom of choice are also
integral parts of finland's foreign
security and defense policy thank you
thank you secretary
thank you again
sweden's partnership with nato is a
central part of our security and defence
policy
our enhanced opportunity partner status
will remain the platform as well as the
30 plus 2 dialogue which we believe is
of mutual importance to sweden finland
and nato
let me first stress how deeply concerned
we are over russia's military
reinforcements around ukraine and
moscow's aggressive rhetoric
this is already the worst ongoing armed
conflict in europe and there has been
almost 15 000 casualties and some 1.5
million internally displaced people
our support for ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity remains firm
european and transatlantic unity is key
i think nato and eu partners have made
it very clear to russia that there is no
place for an armed conflict in europe
and that any further acts of aggression
would be met with massive consequences
sweden has had intense contacts with u.s
and european colleagues within the eu
the osce and with nato on this issue
my visit here today is one such
opportunity to share information and
discuss the current very serious
situation
i want to thank the secretary general
stoltenberg for the close dialogue and
the cooperation that we have
it is particularly important that we
have had this opportunity to meet
together with finland as always we
cooperate very closely with finland
we are closely following developments
carefully analyzing the russian military
buildup of troops and hardware
we are preparing for a number of
scenarios
today we also discussed the proposal put
forward by russia
the core of the proposal is to attempt
to rewrite what we call the european
security order the arrangement for
europe security that were commonly
agreed after the cold war
one of the main principles of this
security order is that every state has
the right to choose its own security
arrangement whom it cooperates with
whether to join or stay in a military
alliance etc
this is what russia wants a road back
and this is not acceptable
let me again reiterate that the
fundamental principles underpinning the
european security security order must
remain non-negotiable
we supported dialogue with russia on
matters such as arms controls rules for
military exercises codes of conduct
confidence building measures this is
something that we are ready to discuss
with russia
having been the chairperson of the ose
for a year i think the ose is the right
forum for such discussions
let me finally and again stress that we
support the ongoing diplomatic efforts
we commend natto for its strong
engagement in the present crisis
and welcome the dialogue between nato
and russia
we expect russia to choose to continue
the dialogue and accept nato's offer to
organize further meetings in the
nato-russia council
thank you
thank you very much we'll take questions
from here uh in the press room and also
we'll try to take a couple of questions
online
we'll go to uh swedish tv gentlemen in
the second row
mr secretary general
uh what was the outcome of today's
meeting and how will this situation
affect nato's relationship with sweden
for nato and for me it is extremely
important to have very close
consultations with
finland and sweden and to share analysis
and to share assessments as we face a
very challenging security situation
in
europe because of the
military buildup in and around ukraine
by russia and also because of the
threatening rhetoric by russia
and i think we all agree on the need to
uh pursue a diplomatic path i i hope
that the uh both aninda and pekka have
still on the diplomatic efforts of nato
the fact that we had a meeting of the
nato-russia council for the first time
for a long time
i think that was a positive sign at
least a step in the right direction and
that nato has invited russia to
participate in further meetings in a
series of meetings in the nato russia
council and outland also the different
areas we are ready
to discuss with russia
at the same time of course we we are we
are working for the best we are hoping
for the best but we have to be prepared
prepared for the worst meaning that we
also
are
as nato are increasing our presence
in the eastern part of the uh the
alliance
um you asked about uh what this means
for the relationship with
nato and sweden well i think it
highlights the importance of the close
relationship
that
fully respecting the swedish decision to
not be a
nato member we welcome very much the
close partnership
sweden is an enhanced opportunity
partner
sweden and finland are our most
closest partners and
the fact that we work together that we
share information that we exercise
together
is something
which
is important and the importance is
demonstrated in the situation we are
faced with now
let me add
finally that
i welcome the
the fact that uh sweden has uh
reinforced its uh military presence uh
um
at kotlin because that is important for
the whole baltic sea so it's a strategic
importance for
for the baltic sea and of course nato uh
is present there we have literal states
there and the nato allies have also uh
increased its suppressants uh in the
baltic sea uh region
we go to helsinki insanomat lady
yeah mr stoltenberg as you said uh nato
is sending reinforcements in eastern
europe could you be a bit more precise
what is nato's response to increased
russian military presence in the baltic
sea
so i i have
i've listed some of the additional
deployments
with more air policing with more naval
presence currently there are
five nato ships in the baltic sea region
we are also strengthening our
presence in the air with the with the
air policing
we already have deployed
battle groups
nato multinational battle groups to the
three baltic countries and poland
and we are uh for the first time in the
dec in the decade we have
um a a us aircraft carry group and the
nato command that that is not in the
baltic sea but of course it matters for
the security uh of uh the whole of
europe so we have uh stepped up uh but
this is defensive and nato is not
threatening uh russia it's proportionate
and
at the same time as we
step up we also
invite russia to
continue our dialogue because we
are ready to engage
in good faith
in
in the efforts to find a political
solution we are ready to listen to the
russian security concerns
also in the baltic region
but we will not compromise on the right
for every nation to choose his own path
and that also applies for sweden finland
for
for for other european nations uh and
not of course compromise on nato's right
to protect and defend all allies but
again
i think what we see now
uh with the increased tensions the
deteriorating security situation just
highlights the importance of the very
close partnership we have built with
finland and sweden over the last years
including in the baltic region with
exercises with uh
with uh with a high degree of
interoperability um and under very close
political consultations
that was also demonstrated today with a
meeting with the two foreign ministers
okay gentleman over here
thank you andreas lillard on swedish
public radio um
two questions if i may
you talk about increasing the
cooperation between nato and sweden can
you be more concrete what could this
increase in cooperation look like and
secondly
we see now an increase in defense
capacity in eastern europe
do you see any
risks that did this might actually
create further tensions or if it could
be used by russia to
to be even more aggressive and feel free
if you like to answer in scandinavia
okay then i think our answer in scandan
um
um
foreign
is
and
[Music]
okay we'll go to the finnish news agency
the lady in pink
thank you
from the phoenix news agency uh
secretary general you already mentioned
that the political
cooperation and the exercises are very
important this situation but what else
is nato expecting from its close member
those close partners or close partners
in this kind of situation and i would
also like to hear from the foreign
ministers what is uh finland and sweden
where are you ready to offer for this
cooperation and situation thank you
oh that can be very brief because the
one way our answer is the the main
issues that we work together in many
different uh
ways on exercises on training on
on just improving the way we can operate
together and and finland and sweden have
participated in different nato missions
and operations uh from afghanistan iraq
uh maritime deployments uh to our
presidency in the western balkans and
and we are all ready to step up and to
do more uh and also to share more
information and to share more
situational awareness and again when we
see high tensions especially
in the eastern part alliance and
including also
in the baltic region of course uh we
share information with finland and
sweden they share information with us
that's good for their security it's good
for our security and uh and
that is highlighted with
the the the situation we see uh
now
maybe from the finnish perspective uh
one remark on the current situation when
russo has made the proposals on here
what is going on and and that things are
not decided over the heads of the
countries that are not nato members or
are not directly involved in these talks
and of course there also comes the
importance of the oacs organization and
the helsinki final act and the paris
charter and those by the european
security principles this has to be taken
into consideration secondly like
secretary general said the sharing of
the information is very important in
this kind of that we have the common
analysis of the situation and then of
course our experience and our continued
continuing uh
programs for training and and common
exercises and so forth so this
technical cooperation military
cooperation of course is with nato has
been very intensive and we are doing it
on the benefit of our own security and
our own defense capability
yes just to say
i can just agree
what a gentleman has said but also the
political dialogue is very important and
there was for several years there was
no taking part of foreign ministers
in the foreign minister's meeting but
now i and
finnish foreign minister has taken part
both in brussels and riga on different
kind of important uh discussions and for
example
when we give our information and
analyzes what's happening in the high
north and arctic is where we have also
special
experiences
so that has been very
well received i also would say is it's
not like it's a one-way street
as secretary general said about gotland
and
having
the possibility in the baltic sea for
for also our troops to show that we have
a strong defense i would remind that
sweden has increased
our military spending since uh 2014 when
the annexation of crimea and so on with
80 percent
that's quite a high
increase in our military spending
we go to kaupalecti the lady in green
thank you
i work for the finnish paper called
palestine
as we all know secretary general russian
president vladimir putin has demanded
that nato stops expanding in europe
however um in a recent interview the
finnish
president saolinista
had with the german newspaper zeit he
said that in his interpretation the
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
has withdrawn with thrawn
these demands when it comes to sweden uh
and finland and i would like to know if
you share
his interpretation has
russia with
drawn its demands
what we have seen is what they have
proposed in the
proposals for illegally binding
agreements or treaties between nato and
and russia and that was
submitted to us
some weeks ago
in parallel with the
proposed treaty between russia and
united states there are two proposals on
the table uh for legally binding
agreements between russia and united
states and russia and nato
and in
the treaty with the proposed draft
treaty with nato it is clearly stated
that
there should be no further enlargement
of
nato
with any country
so based on that uh it is clear what
nato what what russia has demanded
and we are ready to sit down and discuss
many issues with uh russia on arms
control transparency and uh and the
security situation in europe including
the situation in around ukraine but we
are not ready to discuss core principles
for european security
and as the finnish
president has stated and many other
leaders both in finland and sweden have
stated is that is that it is for finland
to decide if they want to apply for
membership in nato and then it's for
finland and 30 nato allies to decide
uh
finally uh on the issue of membership
and that's exactly the same for sweden
so
i just based my uh
assessments on what russia has put
forward in a written
proposal for a legally binding
agreement banning any further
enlargement of nato
and
my message is that
nato's door remain open and then we will
respect
seven independent decisions by sovereign
independent countries like finland and
sweden on whether they
would like to apply for membership or
not
okay i see one more question here and
then we'll take a couple online
gentlemen over here
mtv finland uh usa and uh united kingdom
have started uh already to move family
members
of personnel to leave ukraine should all
nato and
eu members do now same
order
this has to be a national uh
decision we share information uh among
nato allies we also share
information with the close partners as
fin and sweden we have nato personnel
in kiev we have two nato offices in kiev
we we of course assess and follow the
situation
closely but we have not made any
decision to
to withdraw those people working for
nato in uh in gear
okay we'll go online
to
club zed media group mom chill in job
thank you
my question is to secretary general
well
as it became clear today and you you
told it recently the nato allies began
to send more ships and jets to enhance
deterrence and defense in eastern europe
and are there any plans to deploy
immediately more troops in the
southeastern flank of nato especially in
bulgaria romania and
and turkey and has nato met a new risk
assessment and so could you please
specify thank you
also we are constantly assessing the
risks and we are constantly sharing
information among allies
and we have stepped up our capabilities
to collect information um one of the
reasons why we have increased our
presence in the
in the black sea region is
is just uh
uh to be able to monitor and to follow
the situation very closely to collect
more information
so our presence our increased presence
uh
in the eastern part of lawrence and in
particular in the black sea region
is partly to
collect information to assess the
situation very closely but also of
course
to be
able to respond to any situation that
will require a response from a nato
allied country so i think this is
prudent behavior what we do is defensive
it's proportionate and it's a full in
line with our international obligations
and of course the nato presence is in no
way threatening
because it is
compared to the significant military
buildup by russia in around ukraine
a very limited
presence but it sends a strong signal
and message
of our unity and our resolve to protect
and defend all allies we are considering
to further increase our presence
also in the southeast of the
alliance
and we are considering also
to
have battle groups
not only in the baltic region but also
on poland but also in the southeast of
the alliance but no decision has been
taken
we will assess and
make the decisions when the time is
right
next question online goes to terry
schultz from deutsche bade
hi thank you very much
um this is a question for for all three
um officials there um
i i just came back from sweden as a
matter of fact and it was explained to
me that um the country feels secure
without nato membership because there
are so many partnerships um and
also because of the fact that if gotland
for example were attacked it would be in
nato's own interest to come to the
defense of sweden so do all three of you
agree that that is enough of a security
guarantee without article 5 for this
region and then just a second question
because of course i'm reporting for
germany um mr secretary general are you
appointed in germany um for the comments
of the naval team
for the comments of the naval chief that
said that uh russia that russian
president putin deserves respect and
also in its in its refusal to allow uh
military equipment from estonia to be
delivered to ukraine as finland in fact
has has allowed thank you very much
so first on on the on the article five i
think it will leave it to the to the
finnish and swedish uh
foreign ministers to to
reflect on that
as i said we are have extremely close
partnership with both finland and sweden
then of course there is a difference
between membership and not membership
and and and and that is something uh
sweden and finland has to
assess and make their own decisions we
will not interfere or try to
influence those discussions in
finland and and sweden we respect their
decisions
then
on germany the germany is a nato ally
they have agreed
to
send the same messages as we have done
in nato over some time now with
both the message of readiness for
dialogue with russia
the nato russia council and we are now
working on our uh written proposals that
we will convey to russia in the near
future
and germany is of course is strongly
part of that but german is also part of
the
the increased presence in eastern part
of the the alliance germany is leading
the battlegroup in lithuania and and and
what we do now is that
we are
stepping up within existing nato
frameworks to air policing uh the
standing
naval forces of nato
and another existing
nato forced structures and again this is
something germany has agreed to and and
german also contributes so
nato allies are united in their response
to
their threatening russian military
buildup both when it comes to dialogue
but also when it comes to
sending a message of unity and strength
from the finnish perspective finland of
course is a democratic country and our
decisions are based on the opinion of
the people and political parties the
majority has not been in favor of the
nato
membership but
for the close partnership with nato
which we currently have and our defense
doctrine builds on maintaining a strong
national defense capability we have a
conscription army we have 280 000
reservists in finland we have just
made a decision to renew our fighter
capacity to f-35 and and so forth
and and of course we are increasing our
preparedness and readiness whenever
there are new security concerns we have
been investing also quite a lot to to to
tackle the hybrid new kinds of hybrid
and cyber threats but the close
cooperation with nato of course is
something that people support
and i would say that of course every
country has to
see what is the best way of keeping our
country and our people out of war what
will keep them safe
and that is how you determine what kind
of security arrangement you want to have
and for us in sweden we are military
non-aligned
and
that that is something that has served
us very well during very very difficult
times and we think it still serves us
well together with a strong defense and
i just mentioned here earlier since 2014
we have increased our the defense
spending with 80 percent and with close
cooperation uh with other partners we
have about 20 agreements with countries
nato countries
other countries
organizations and the closest
partnership we have is with finland
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference thank you thank you so
much
[Music]
you